we ended the last movie in Washington DC
and that's where we pick it up with
Miller in desperate straits and humanity
on the verge of extinction now we're on
a clock there really is no time for
Alice to do what she needs to do to
destroy the t-virus and also now there's
a need for her to understand who she is
and how she got here she's running to
sort of base herself and her history so
there's a lot at stake
humanity will cease to exist unless you
are drawn to the hive
this movie brings everything to a
conclusion you discover the truth about
the Alice character the truth about the
Red Queen and the ultimate agenda of the
umbrella corporations alone
but now it's over I think this is bar
none the best of them all we shot in
Cape Town South Africa which is a place
of extremes I mean the elements were all
around us the Sun is so bright it's a
blinding and the wind is whipping in
your ear we really like the gnarliest
buildings they'd find these wacked
concrete run-down locations and
everything is like dirty and grimy and
he got sand and stuff spraying in her
face and it's 4:00 in the morning and
we're jumping into lakes and it was a it
was intense that we shot seven weeks of
nights so we were just like dirtier
faster pushing it at all times like as
much as we could and I think that you
can feel that in this movie it's like
really raw and it's really palpable
because it's a big movie and it's got a
big sound and it's got these huge
explosions and all sorts of crazy stuff
when I first read the script I just
immediately thought of like that massive
scope and that energy and it's just it's
a big movie those are the only kind of
movies that you can really see no much
you know
we the the farm at big screen I think
people when they go to IMAX they're
gonna really enjoy it from beginning to
end
I've always been about making movies
from industry and that's why it's always
such a pleasure to see what I do on an
IMAX screen we got the biggest and most
explosive locations we could I mean two
miles of abandoned freeway this huge
tunnel that went two miles on the ground
I think to appreciate these giant
locations and the big action you know
seeing it on a big screen is really
there's no other place that I think you
should watch resident except Isaac's
because it's got so much sound it's got
so much high impact action it's
terrifying things are jumping out at you
and when you have it like that big in
front of you I mean it just gets sucked
into the world
you